je commence la vidéo heureusement mais
pas tous j'espère vous allez bien
aujourd'hui on va se parler d'un produit
j'ai déjà présenté et quelques jours
dont je vous ai déjà parlé eux l'oit on
vous invite à vous prendre une petite
canette quelle qu'elle soit un verre
d'eau ce que vous voulez on se pose en
garde ça en étant on est vachement bien
regardez moi je poserai m'entourent pas
idée commence à faire des vidéos ont ce
stage
voilà bravo bravo monsieur groupe ce
nouveau ordinateur c'est celui là c'est
le lenovo thinkpad x1 fold paul pourquoi
parce qu'ils se plient à l'ordinateur
avec un écran qui se plie alors pour
mieux le voir je vous enlève la partie
clavier au centre et il fait attention
de reflets et beaucoup de lumière et 6 à
ce prix et c'est vraiment une super
machine extrêmement intéressante elle
nous montre une possible vision de
l'ordinateur du futur avec un usage
c'est le fait de rétrécir les écrans la
miniature à miniature une
miniaturisation que je me disais même
plus parler la miniaturisation des
produits tout simplement parce qu'on va
réduire l'encombrement en venant prier
on va venir gagner forcément en
épaisseur ont fait la taille d'un gros
bouquin pour moi reghem bien des cônes
là-dessus ça marche très bien
donc la question qu'on va se pose
aujourd'hui c'est est ce que c'est un
nouvel ordinateur ce thinkpad x1 fold de
lenovo a un intérêt pour vous est-ce
qu'il peut vous tentez est-ce qu'il peut
vous intéresser
on va parler des usages on va essayer de
comprendre ce qu'on peut faire avec ce
qu'on ne peut pas faire avec parce qu'on
ne peut pas tout faire avec
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec soeur sharks
sauf sharks et un vpn qui vit à protéger
vos connexions internet
il va notamment éviter les fluctuations
de prix lorsque vous allez venir faire
vos achats en ligne par exemple réserver
un billet d'avion louer une voiture ou
encore prendre un hôtel mais il va
beaucoup plus loin puisqu'il vous
protègent leurs nouveaux connexion sur
les wifi public par exemple un
restaurant ou bien encore d'un hôtel
lorsque vous êtes en déplacement il
vient cryptée et sécuriser vos données
mais vous permet également de vous
connecter à des sites internet qui sont
bloqués par un g au blocage je pense
notamment à netflix les bibliothèques de
netflix usd de flics ce japon si vous
êtes aux us netflix france c'est la même
chose pour my canal va pouvoir vous
connecter dans le monde entier et ça
très bien avec un seul abonnement vous
pouvez connecter un nombre illimité
d'appareils en même temps est surchargé
disponible sur pc / mac ios android
smart tv apple tv chrome firefox xbox et
même playstation vous bénéficiez d'une
assistance 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7 et vous êtes satisfait ou
remboursé dans les 30 jours qui suivent
votre souscription en plus de sa soeur
sharks ne conserve aucune de vos données
et vous bénéficiez de service en plus
comme soeur sharks à leers qui vous
alertera si vous donnez personnel ont
fuité sur internet afin que vous
puissiez changer vos mots de passe et
surtout mais pour naviguer sur le web en
toute confidentialité sans publicité ni
traceur vous invite donc à venir
découvrir et essayer sur chirac nous a
mis un lien en bas dans la description
bénéficier de 95 % de remise et de
quatre mois offerts lenovo thinkpad x1
folle déjà je vais vous parler un peu
des différentes façon dont on va pouvoir
venir l'utiliser la toute première façon
c'est en ouvrant comme ça en grand c'est
un ordinateur c'est vraiment un
ordinateur vous êtes sur un windows
windows disent là dessus rien de bien
surprenant bon vous couler sur windows
pas vous en parler ça c'est relativement
simple vous pouvez donc soin de tenir
comme une tablette si vous le souhaitez
soit à venir utiliser ce petit rabat
pour le mettre en autre cheval et vous
le poser sur une table pour du
visionnage pourquoi pas ça serait
intéressant puis même pour travailler
avec ou sans stylet mais ça on en
reparle dans quelques instants
ça c'est la toute première configuration
la deuxième configuration s'est voulu
plier vous ne payez vous le métier sur
une table vous le mettez sur vos genoux
vous avez donc cet écran qui
fonctionnent d'une seule et même parti
qui est très sympa vous pouvez utiliser
la partie diot pour mettre une fenêtre
la partie du bas pour maintenant notre
fenêtre pourrait donc faire une espèce
de multitâche par contre ce qui est un
peu un peu dur c'est lorsqu'il est quand
même puis à 90 degrés pour venir passer
ici au niveau de la pliure bon voilà
c'est pas extrêmement simple c'est un
peu l'inconvénient de ces avantages
comme vous le déplier un petit peu plus
et là c'est quand même un petit peu plus
facile
bon voilà ça c'est vraiment du pain de
détails et puis le troisième usage et
non des moindres c'est lorsque vous
venez poser sont tus clavier ici qui
segmente vous avez donc que la partie du
haut qui est activée l'écran du bas en
dessous est complètement désactivé et là
vous l'utiliser comme un petit pc très
très facilement donc on a ces trois
façons un peu basique ayant plus de ça
après on vient rajouter des usages grâce
au stylet ça c'est aussi super
intéressant pour la prise de notes on va
une fois de plus le détail et dans
quelques instants
pour devenir un bouger vos fenêtres ou à
le faire avec ou sans le clavier à
chacun de trouver ces usages sa façon de
fonctionner en tout cas moi ce que je
trouve intéressant déjà tout de suite
c'est d'avoir ce côté modulaire chacun
donc pour me retrouver ses usages très
facilement
on peut le ranger aussi d'une façon très
très très maline vous posez le clavier
vous remettez le style est ici tac ça
vient ça ce poste vous le refermer et
vous êtes parti on voit que là on a fait
un ordinateur qui est fait pour être
emmener partout avec soit rangé très
facilement pour du déplacement
professionnel pour du voyage voilà ça
c'est son adn fait une chaleur sous ses
spots
on va se recentrer sur les points un peu
pratique au niveau cette machine premier
point ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
vous avez sur l'ordinateur en lui-même
c'est à dire sans le clavier et sans le
stylet vous avez un port usb qui va se
trouver juste en dessous de la façade
principale celle usbco et vous en avez
un deuxième si vous le posez en votre
cheval est comme ça sur une table est
bien celui que vous avez en dessous sera
condamné dont vous avez vous dire
utiliser celui que vous avez sur le côté
et a contrario si vous le posez comme ça
vous êtes pouvoir choisir d'utiliser
celui en dessous celui sur le côté à
votre convenance vous allez pouvoir
venir recharger votre ordinateur grâce
aux deux prises usb c'est celle que vous
souhaitez venir brancher un disque dur
externe enfin voyons comprenez
l'histoire c'est très très simple
autrefois que je trouve très pratique
extrêmement malin votre clavier l'avenir
se recharger en induction il est aimanté
nouvelle fois venir recharger en
adduction soit sinon vous avez tout
petit prix sur le côté en micro usb pour
recharger comme vous voulez le seul
point j'ai trouvé un petit peu négatif
au niveau de la charge assez pour venir
recharger le style et c'est vraiment je
trouve un peu old school c'est un point
à améliorer pour les nouveaux vous
l'ouvrez et là vous venez recharger en
usb si ça fait penser aux systèmes de
charge qu'on avait sur les premiers
stylet d'apple ou le brancher sur votre
tablette espèce de truc qui dépassait ce
n'était pas très beau
aujourd'hui c'est corrigé vous avez de
la recharge sans fil chez apple ici
c'est pas le cas j'aurais aimé que pour
un produit hyper technologique avec un
écran qui explique qu'on trouve un
système de recharge sans fil
ça m'aurait paru assez malin assez
simple je sais pas non plus critiquer
critiquer parce que il ya eu beaucoup de
reproches quand elle fait aux tablettes
de samsung ou lorsque vous posez votre
stylet comme ça et qu'il veut se
recharge à induction est bien quand on
est en déplacement on le perd même s'il
est aimanté même s'il tient moment il ya
une contrainte seule bouche salon lèvres
au le père voilà donc ici vous le mettez
là ça ne bougera pas le point négatif
c'est que vous devez recharger pour
l'induction
on peut pas tout avoir dites moi vous ce
que vous en pensez on va en commentaire
quel système de préférer en adduction
qu'ils puissent bouger un peu plus ou
alors qu'à l'est comme ça dans cette
petite sangle et qui ne bouge pas voyez
pas ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire parlons un peu des usages
parce que c'est vraiment le point qui va
venir nous intéresser ici alors qu'est
ce qu'on va faire de cette jolie petite
bête noire des gens on va la regarder
parce qu'elle est belle on va se dire
quelle belle technologie et que la
technologie évolue cas du progrès et ça
c'est très cool bravo lenovo pour
l'innovation je vous le dis tout de
suite
ici on tourne sur un intel core i5 on
est sur un live feed on va pas être sur
une machine extrêmement performante dont
vous allez pas avoir beaucoup de
performances tout ce qui va être montage
vidéo 2d et photoshop par exemple avec
beaucoup de calme c'est pas forcément
cette machine qui est fait pour vous
puisqu'elle n'aura pas beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de performances à
l'intérieur néanmoins son intérêt c'est
qu'elle est extrêmement polyvalente et
vous emmener partout avec vous alors
pour moi l'intérêt principal que vous
allez retrouver ça va être pour toute
une partie productivité productivité
avancés avec de la modularité
vous êtes en déplacement vous avez un
rendez vous professionnel vous avez un
ordinateur avec un tout petit écran pour
le coup ici mais si vous vous dites je
veux un plus grand écran et je pouvoir
l'utiliser avec mon clavier bien vous
enlevez votre clavier il va se connecter
en bluetooth directement pourrait soit
le poser à plat soit sur le mode
chevalet et là vous avez un écran quand
même un peu plus grands ils avouent
venez l'utiliser comme ça je puis vous
assurer qu'ils ont été rudes usages
c'est super cool et personnellement
j'aime beaucoup je me suis vraiment
régalé en l'utilisant comme ça c'est
très bien le clavier même s'il peut
paraître un peu plus tu surtout
extrêmement fin et si vous vous en
douterez on n'est pas sur un ordinateur
classique donc on a pas de danger on n'a
pas à côté un peu repose poignets on a
un tout petit trackpad
mais une fois de plus on est sur une
machine qu'on va venir prendre lorsqu'on
va se déplacer
peut-être en complément d'un pc un peu
plus gros à la maison pour l'usagé
familial ça c'est vraiment la machine
qu'on va prendre plus quand on se
déplace alors c'est un certain coup
quand on se déplace on est un peu moins
de 3000 euros la machine certes certes
c'est pour ça que je vous dis une fois
de plus pour cet ordinateur n'est pas
destiné à tout le monde
l'usagé du stylet moi j'avais un petit
peu moins voulait déjà dit lorsque je
vous parle de notamment de smartphones
de la gamme note de samsung avec des
styles et je suis pas monsieur style et
j'utilise pas beaucoup les styles et je
ne fais pas d'illustration je ne dessine
pas que ne prend pas de notes avec un
stylet donc l'usagé gelé pas trop trop
mais pour toutes les personnes qui ont
fait usage là je pense que vous allez
vous régaler ici d'autant plus que ce
stylet effet en partenariat avec moi
comme mais il
plus dans l'idée de l'illustration dans
l'idée de la création
et bien vous n'avez pas beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
performances
si vous êtes illustrateur si vous êtes
dessinateur c'est peut-être pas cette
machine là qu'il vous faudra pour venir
travailler directement avec votre stylet
faudra privilégier une tablette
graphique de très bonne qualité plutôt
qu avait une très jolie machine même si
elle coûte quand même un certain prix
study ordinateur qui se plie charnière
ça c'est un taux qui est très très très
important et vous faut une très bonne
charnière il faut une très très bonne
finition ici on a une très très bonne
finition
pour moi la charnière je trouve robuste
je trouve vraiment bien construite elle
s'arrête partout quel que soit l'angle
que vous souhaitiez avoir très bon
boulot de la part de lenovo là dessus
alors j'avais noté un point sur lequel
j'évolue interrogations mais une fois de
plus aurait pas de réponse tout de suite
c'est peut-être la réponse dans le temps
c'est sur un petit jour que je viens
voir vous avez un mini jours et je me
demandais si à force des impuretés ne
pouvait pas avant très l'intérieur est
ce qu'il y avait pas de risque je n'ai
pas la réponse aujourd'hui
je ne saurais pas vous le dire j'en ai
parlé avec patrick salles et patrick qui
est expert produit chez lenovo est a
priori non je vais essayer de vous
montrer comme ça c'est pas hyper
évidemment filmé dans cette partie juste
au-dessus pas la partie du basque parti
du bas c'est le cuir ça m'intrigue pas
quand on te plais ici là on a un tout
petit jour on se sent vraiment ses sous
pour je me dise ya des impuretés qui
passe là-dedans allez savoir
allez savoir ce qui pourrait se passer
autre point qui est extrêmement
important avec un ordinateur qui se plie
et bien c'est la dalle la qualité
d'alors pour sa spleen ou folie
technologique un écran flexible et
écrans flexibles aujourd'hui sont des
écrans oled c'est ce qu'on appellera une
dalle f oled fold oled une dalle qui se
plie voyez c'est ça hop
bon là dessus vous l'avez vu ça se plie
c'est beau je la trouve de bonne qualité
ça peut vous paraître subjectif
peut-être mais en tout cas j'ai vraiment
apprécié que ce soit pour bien
travailler pour avoir du loisir j'ai
beaucoup travaillé sur nos chaînes pour
préparer toute l'année 2021 sur monsieur
greu jeu les utiliser pour regarder
aussi du contenu multimédia j'ai joué un
petit peu avec et cette dame se trouve
vraiment vraiment sympa assez lumineuse
ça il faut le dire d'autant plus que
c'est un ordinateur portable qu'on m'a
emmené à l'extérieur je sais que c'est
compliqué de se rendre compte au travers
d'une vidéo
moi je suis aussi satisfait un autre
point qui est vachement intéressant qui
est très très malin aujourd'hui vous le
savez je vais
vous apprendre dans une période
compliquée et c'est pas grand chose de
le dire lier cette saloperie de virus et
bien on tout le monde télétravail
beaucoup en tout cas pas tout le monde
et beaucoup télétravail et il nous faut
des ordinateurs performants et nous en
tout cas des machines qui lui permettent
de travail dans de bonnes conditions
avec des webcams de qualité avec des
micros de qualité alors ici un peu qui
est assez sympa et que j'aime bien c'est
que vous n'êtes pas moins de quatre
petits micros up ma feuilleton de nous
et pas moins de quatre petits micros qui
sont situés juste en dessous à côté du
bouton de volume mais à côté des boutons
pour venir l'allumé pour les teintes ce
qui fait que lorsque vous allez utiliser
un ordinateur plier comme ça eh bien
vous avez les micros en face de votre
bouche donc à une vraie directivité on
va vraiment devenir capter ce que vous
dites plutôt bien et si vous l'utilisez
en mode stand c'est-à-dire couvert comme
ça tac tac tac tac
eh bien ces micro vont se retrouver sur
la droite et ce qui me semble aussi plus
tôt plutôt de biens est plutôt
intéressant une seule que je viens un
peu reproché c'est que si vous faites de
la visioconférence vous le ferez
uniquement avec votre ordinateur ouvert
comme ça en mode stand pourquoi parce
que vous avez la webcam qui au centre
parce que si vous le positionner comme
ça vous avez votre webcam qui est
positionné là sur le côté et là ça
devient extrêmement bizarre quand vous
verrez un peu de côté un peu en bien peu
en bas une fois de plus il a fallu faire
des choix et on ne peut pas avoir quinze
mille webcam qui vont se balader tout
autour
vous le mettez en mode stand voyez tous
vos interlocuteurs vous preniez votre
clavier en bout tous c'est à distance ça
fonctionnera comme je le disais ça
ordinateur qui va être extrêmement
performant par contre ce qui est
intéressant avec ce team telle core i5 à
l'aide field est bien c'est que vous
n'avez pas de ventilateur vous n'avez
pas une machine qui va souffler qui va
faire du bruit
une fois de plus et je vous le dis et je
vous le redis vous êtes partenaires du
programme gourmand que tu ne feras pas
besoin de refroidir énormément c'est une
certitude
par contre lorsque vous allez être en
déplacement à bien vous allez avoir une
machine extrêmement silencieuses pas
debout il ya plein de petites
optimisations logiciel sur lequel on
travaille et lenovo qui sont super
intéressantes notamment les nouveaux
display optimizers optimizer optimisé
optimizers je préfère lenovo display
optimizers qui permettra de
personnaliser le spectre colorimétrique
en fonction de chaque application vous
allez utiliser
vous allez donc pouvoir adapter la
colorimétrie de chaque application en
fonction des besoins et des usages
intéressant vous avez une optimisation
également de la caméra et l'audio lens
vous allez dire converser avec des
collègues par exemple est ce qu'ils
appellent le smart display qui vous
permettra de venir flouté votre écran
lorsque vous ne le regardais pas par
exemple vous êtes au bureau
vous vous levez vous allez à la machine
à café bien votre écran va être floutés
parce que vous n'êtes pas en face la
même manière imaginez vous êtes face à
votre ordinateur
ils vont regarder autre chose eh bien
vous voulez pas qu'un curieux ou une
curieuse je viens de regarder et de la
paf ça se floute et lorsque vous le
regardez ils se défoulent août vous
pouvez travailler donc très facilement
en toute sécurité
voyez pas mal de petites options
logicielles sur lequel les nouveaux a
vraiment bien bossé qui vient dans le
sens de la productivité qui s'adresse un
beaucoup là-dessus aux professionnels
dont je trouve ça assez malin vous avez
bien évidemment de la reconnaissance
visuelle avec windows et l'eau pour
venir le déverrouiller façon
complètement sécurisé vous avez la
commande à la voix avec lenovo voice
procès pour lui demander d'ouvrir des
applications d'avoir de la traduction en
temps réel ça peut également être très
intéressant pour les personnes en
situation de handicap il ya beaucoup d'
usage derrière la cible là dessus de
lenovo c'est plus la cible
professionnelle qui veulent des
ordinateurs 13 pouces 14 pouces facile à
emmener avec soi on va donc laisser
venir cibler les personnes qui ont
besoin de mobilité du tram mobilité je
pense notamment à des commerciaux je
pense à des jeux c'est pas moins des
cadres qui se déplacent tout le temps et
qui ont besoin d'avoir un ordinateur qui
prend pas beaucoup de place et s'adresse
aussi là dessus ce qu'on appellera les
early adopters heures les pixies ceux
qui aiment la tête qui veulent les
nouvelles innovations et qui ont les
moyens de le mettre là dedans on a un
petit peu moins de 3000 euros et fait
plus ça va dépendre de la configuration
je vous ai mis des liens en bas dans la
description allait jeter un petit coup
d'oeil ne serait ce que pour découvrir
vous verrez les différentes
configurations c'est intéressant ça
d'ordinateurs là n'est pas fait pour le
commun des mortels c'est une innovation
ça permet à lenovo de montrer qu'ils
sont présents dans l'innovation on le
savait déjà on l'avait déjà vu avec
beaucoup de leurs produits notamment les
yoga qui se plie un peu de tous les
côtés mais là il utilise une fois de
plus ce côté pliable plions pliable qui
ce côté pliable grâce aux nouveaux
écrans qui vous permettent de se plier
grâce à la technologie oled ils peuvent
l'embarqué très facilement avec des
processeurs qui ne consomment pas
énormément mais en ayant effectivement
petit manque de performance si c'est ce
dont vous avez besoin il ira également
bien pour le multimédia pour la
productivité pour le travail pour moi
c'est une machine que vous allez
vraiment mais vraiment utilisé pour
venir travailler
on peut l'utiliser pour jouer à des jeux
pas très performant vous et notamment
fait tourner asphalte 8 dessus balladur
dans plus de performances très très
clairement mais on peut le faire un peu
de divertissement on peut le faire ici
pour moi c'est de la productivité avec
votre clavier bluetooth avec votre
stylet avec votre écran tactile et avec
une machine qui se plie et qu'on peut
utiliser
différentes manières c'est une machine
que je trouve super intéressante
j'approuve limited en plein de points
dans plein de domaines je voulais dire
une fois de plus vous manqués
performance dont vous ne pouvez pas tout
faire vous ne pourrez pas tout faire
mais ce que j'aime ici c'est
l'innovation moi j'adore les novations
j'adore la technologie sinon je ne
ferais pas de suntech vous ne verriez
pas on ne se connaîtraient pas on se
seraient jamais rencontrés
ça aurait été dommage donc j'adore
l'innovation je salue l'innovation mais
je suis convaincu que ce lenovo thinkpad
x1 folle ne se vendra par beaucoup parce
qu'il n'est pas destiné à beaucoup de
monde
il permet de montrer l'innovation il
montre la force de lenovo qui donne un
acteur majeur dans le monde des
ordinateurs mais également dans le monde
de l'innovation
il faut compter sur eux cette magie de
la trouve très queer dites moi vous est
ce que vous pensez qu'un ordinateur
comme ça vous pourriez acheter et si oui
pour quel usage savait pas dire vous
allez l'acheter mais est ce que vous
pourriez vous laisser tenter par une
machine comme ça et qu'est ce que vous
pensez que vous pourriez en faire ça
c'est super intéressant marqué le
mordant commentaires je regardais prends
ton de regarder ça un pouvoir en
discuter ensemble qu'est ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous aimez ce qui
l'ovationnait ce que vous pensez que ça
va dans le bon sens et est ce que vous
pensez que l'avenir du pc passe par le
pay and mark et moi ça en bas catalans
retrouvent très vite pour continuer à
parler de teck de l'amour des bisous et
du love 15 15